[Music]
i have some questions about the
geography of this weekly intro splaining
the map seems to indicate coast-to-coast
mountains on this part of the island but
as soon as we clear the first mountain
we see the fire nation somehow invading
on the opposite shore toward the
mountains
not only is this geography impossible
but this is simply an awful invasion
strategy
also those ships are way too big to be
parked that close to the shore
previously on avatar i'm sick of every
show having previously on segments
just pay attention the first time do we
really have such short attention spans
that we can't even find a way to hold on
to the information that
wait what was i talking about again
you're like my sister
i mean if you remove the murderous rage
character trait azula is op
so aang should be thrilled to be
compared to her it's made me who i am
and now i will turn my facial scars
towards the camera for full effect
and honestly zuko is only alone through
part of this episode and if you include
the strange ostrich horse he rides then
zuko is never alone this episode title
is a lie
this slab of meat is being held away
from the embers by sticks magical sticks
that are apparently immune to fire how
is this not a more important discovery
in this episode
this should be all about the magical
fire sticks and the development of their
clever marketing slogan
stick so magical that flames won't come
up also whoever decided not to center
the bonfire needs to be slapped with a
hot stake
side effects of pregnancy may include
constant urination swollen limbs
occasional heartburn and not being
murdered for your food
also zuko decides against attacking this
young family but couldn't he have just
asked nicely for a bite or two maybe in
exchange he could have katara deliver
their baby later on
just an idea also also in this world do
people carry around perfectly butchered
slices of meat for streamside camping
i guess they do because here we are i'm
just wondering where they butchered the
animal in what container they
transported this steak slab inside of so
that they could cook it way the [ __ ] out
here instead of at home these are not
matching dice
if both of them are oriented to see the
five and the one in the same way then
the third side should be the same as
well
if one egg causes this much splatter and
two yolks then nobody should be hungry
in this town
also i know animation has its limits but
it always bothers me when eggs break in
cartoons because the egg whites should
only be white
after it cooks before it's cooked we
should call them like egg snots instead
and these egg snot should not be this
white egg had to come from somewhere
maybe a chicken flew over yes but which
came first i'm guessing the rooster
i'll take you to my house and feed your
ostrich horse for you why would his
ostrich want to eat horse
why are these two cow pig sheep pig
animals out of the pen when the rest of
the livestock are locked up
doesn't the farmer know that this is how
you negatively impact the social
complexities of livestock isn't that how
farming works
no one can ever sneak up on us yeah
forget about having sexy time with the
farmer wife because these squeals are a
mood killer i mean unless
they aren't anyone who can hold his own
against those bullies soldiers is
welcome here
apparently not anyone spoiler alert they
kick zuko's ass to the street as soon as
he gives his name
can we all just take a moment to
appreciate this diamond-shaped shadow on
farmer dude's chest
we could toss a ping-pong ball in there
stop asking the man personal questions
got it
yeah kid maybe ask him have you ever
used a hammer and nail before
because clearly zuko is having trouble
comprehending how a metal spike should
pierce the wood plank to the frame
zuko's all like i will put the nails
everywhere and smash with hammer
oh my god that is so cute look at all
the little webby feet and the fluffy
tail and that adorable shell
um sent off for creative animals that i
want but also the shell does make it
harder to get to the tender meat
so stupid turtle duck in a partridge in
a pear tree
cartwheeling's not a game well not with
that attitude it's not
you two are such [ __ ] i believe the
word you are lacking in your grade
school vocabulary is
[ __ ] i hope you all may see it
someday
if we don't burn it to the ground first
is that joke actually funny i know fire
nation are kind of the bad guys here but
that's some
family fun time psychopath right there
you're holding them all wrong
and yet they are stabbing very
effectively so sure teach the kid about
the concept behind the weapon but if
this kid needed to kill someone i'm
pretty sure he'd be fine
so we've seen pig cows pig sheep and pig
roosters on this farm and all i know is
that means there are multiple flavors of
bacon remember how people talked about
leaving the blue people avatar movie and
thinking the world was dull and then
falling into a funk
yeah this is my version of that 3d
inscription made
in earth kingdom the other one
sure it's funny but they had that
inscribed we all know they used tiny
stickers or stamps for that
what is wrong with that child well the
writers probably figured that they
needed a really evil villain so they
decided to make her a psychopath even as
a child since it was easier than dealing
in the nuance of how evil can grow even
in good people
father revoke ira's birthright is fire
gramps blind
because this scene jacob and esau so
hard i'm surprised he doesn't feel up
his chest hair in order of stew
you must know the pain of losing a
first-born son
by sacrificing your own and now we're
abraham and isaac
make up your allegorical mind already i
know we barely know you but
that's true also true you had no way of
knowing what field he would have
conveniently stopped in to conveniently
lounge by the river he's not even on a
road
you're not soldiers you're bullies
you're sick
cowards messing with a family who's
already lost one son to the war
but why i've waited long enough to talk
about these earth-hole soldiers and
their hate boner for this family they
ride all the way out to their farm to
rub it in their faces that their son is
gone and then they basically kidnap the
other son and tie him to a post
what did the pig cow rooster sheep clan
ever do to you to have this kind of
target on their back
give him a left left it's not a fist
fight he's got a left sword don't he
spectators who are you we've done enough
batman outtakes that i think i can
safely just call this a who are you
cliche at this point
move on you were father of ira
father of ozai great this episode
finishes its old testament by going full
genealogy now i'm getting flashbacks to
reading genesis when enoch was born to
irad who begat mahujal who begat
methuselah
who begat laymak
i'm so lonely i paid a hobo to spoon
with me
if you've ever wanted to know what it's
like to probe into the back end of
cinemasins and learn our deepest darkest
secrets behind the sins podcast is just
what you need
each week writers aaron that's me today
that's me and jonathan yep discuss what
it takes to create the content that you
enjoy on youtube hopefully enjoy
they probably do i mean even if they
don't we talk about it that's true i
guess i'll just wrap this up real quick
and let you know that you can listen to
behind the scenes
here on youtube or search for the show
on your favorite podcast player yep
all right hi i'm earth have we met
don't you want to try some of this meat
before you go it's just about ready
i'll see you around grandpa
[Music]
so you can never be sure if a stick is
magic or not until you
try it
hammer what a savings
[Music]
i don't even know where he got a knife
that's not a knife that's a knife
i'll get your son back give me back my
son
who are you i'm batman